what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time where
wall street is trying to get rich to us
that's just trying to get our lunch
money right
i'm here with paulina my my forehead is
extra shiny today just for you guys it's
more like a five head but
nobody's talking about that let's get
into it block five now the sponsor of
lunch money
munch money is now you're proud no
block five is now the proud sponsor
which means you can go to block fine get
a interest bearing account we can earn
up to 8.6 apy
in that account or you can sign up no
yawning for their new
bitcoin rewards credit card that'll pay
you in bitcoin back rather than cash or
airline miles so
head on over to blockfy.com
all right i i personally don't know
where you got this news from so i don't
know what's going on but apparently
morgan stanley the largest u.s brokerage
is embracing
bitcoin what are they doing
[Applause]
breaking news ain't nobody
knowing what's going on but
i'm out here tweeting all the news
because people know
that if you tell me it and you say maybe
we should get the word out that's what
i'm going to do so morgan stanley's in
the game they released a report
this morning all about how bitcoin has
become an investable
asset but even bigger better
and better than that is that nydig
and galaxy digital they
both have been onboarded and now
what we are watching is that morgan
stanley is gonna have two bitcoin funds
that they're gonna bring to all their
clients
bang bang game on you know that bitcoin
is inevitable it's gonna be
awesome this means now that people on
the morgan stanley platform will be able
to buy bitcoin via these funds
hello mass adoption hello mass adoption
all right amazon has surpassed walmart
as the number itself looking at your
phone
well amazon has surpassed walmart as the
number one apparel retailer in the us
thanks in large parts of the pandemic
fueled e-commerce
boom people are shopping for apparel on
amazon
ubs estimates that amazon's u.s sales of
apparel and footwear grew by roughly 15
in 2020 to more than 41 billion which is
20 to 25
above rival walmart why is amazon seeing
such a surge
look they have done a fantastic job
of embracing digital they've done all
sorts of online grocery delivery type
stuff
they've done all sorts of e-commerce
they are
a digital business now and they've also
partnered with several like
luxury brands several numerous luxury
brands
um so yeah there's people who are
shopping for luxury apparel on
amazon.com which is wild
crazy crazy crazy all right shake shack
has partnered with uber eats on a new
delivery service that will be offered
within the shake shack
app um and shake shack added two million
new customers to its digital channels
from march 2020 through january 2021.
wow so why is it launching its own
nationwide in-app delivery
service why would ubereats want to do
that why would shake shack want to do
that
well you got to remember that all of
these folks want to uh have vertical
integration they want to own the
relationship with the customer and so
by doing this uh it's a really
interesting way for uber basically
to start to say wait we're a platform so
whether you do it via the uber app or
you do it through shake shack imagine if
uber powered everything
across all of these different um
restaurants apps it's possibility
so pretty cool to see and very very
smart from uber's perspective do you
think more
uh chains and like stores are gonna do
that restaurants i think that they
probably definitely want to
but we'll see all right
hold on uh oh not loading not
loading it's loading keith roboy
who is a venture capitalist now living
in miami he
he has a new startup called open store
that will buy up
e-commerce businesses and open store a
stealthy company plans to acquire a
number of small
e-commerce businesses according to axios
uh the last startup robot formed was
open door
a home buying and selling platform so
what do we think open source will be
based in miami
where keith loudly relocated to last
year from silicon valley
well i think that uh look this is a very
very very smart business
and as you can imagine uh you can see
e-commerce stores are exploding and if
you can go and buy them up at a
discount and then turn around and get
all sorts of uh economies of scale
you win so when you say e-commerce
stores
do you mean like like people selling on
amazon like small businesses selling on
amazon
well you have to remember that uh let's
say like an amazon
storefront or a shopify store or
whatever if you go in you just buy up
those businesses
it's almost like a private equity type
play
right but you're doing it in a really
unique way
all online all right boston red sox
majority owner
john henry has agreed to sell a roughly
11
stake in the team's parent company to
red bird capital partners
axios has confirmed with the source
close to the situation
separately lebron james has acquired
around a one percent stake in the club
although without investing any new money
that's interesting
it's a massive return on investment for
john henry
who in 2001 paid what was then a record
700 million for the red sox
the deal values its parent company
fenway sports group at around 7.3
billion dollars almost 10x 10x
and but yeah but okay yeah 10x but 700
million in 2001
is crazy absolutely nuts that's what
happens though
lebron shout out go goat james
goat james next all right is it ask
lunch money time just ask lunch money
hashtag ask lm in the comments below
we have a great question today ready
from kate miller let's do
it all right what up kate she said when
will millennials gen z or the next
generation begin feeling the
ramifications of the national debt
i.e when will we have to start paying it
back what a great question
kate we ain't paying it back are you
crazy the aliens are
we ain't paying it back we're just going
to inflate our way out of it that's the
whole idea here is we're going to
basically devalue the currency we're
going to pay it back with
other dollars later we ain't paying it
back everybody knows that the national
debt these people are playing with it
like a little
yo-yo some of you all remember the
little yo-yo you would it would go down
on the string
but every once in a while the string
would just stay long and the yo-yo would
stay it wouldn't come back up when you
snapped your wrist
that's what the national debt is it's
staying down there it ain't coming back
we're literally just going to continue
to increase the national debt
unfortunately which ends up meaning that
we're going to continue to devalue the
currency it's going to lead to
some levels of higher inflation and
ultimately it hurts the bottom percent
of people so after today's moist comment
i am convinced that it's actually
anthony being moist
and i'll be very disappointed if that's
the case but before i get to it it's
moist day 25 today also what
month will it be when we get to day 90
i'm not a mathematician let's go no come
on no i have like three minutes and then
i got things to do
i'm busy i'm a busy guy so moist
counter he said day 24 of commenting
the most important thing about gatorade
is that they're referred to by their
color and not their official flavor
that being said my favorite flavor of
gatorade is purple
yeah that's impossible nobody likes
purple except him and apparently moist
uh followed closely by dark blue also
same that is insane
also i think i just found the right
gabriella on twitter it fits the
description she gave but her most recent
tweet is from 2015 so i'm not sure
moist you got a gatorade you're a
gatorade aficionado but you are not
an internet user because if you can't
find it we found gabrielle
i didn't she did well so gabriella
compton said
hi moist i don't think that's me here's
another clue my bio says what my
profession is followed by the hashtag
bitcoin also someone else found my
username already and posted it in one of
my comments
come on boys come on she's give it like
okay hold on hold on and then we got a
comment hey again i am gabriella's 12
year old brother
hashtag ask ellen can you tell moise
that i want to do a meeting with him to
see if he is a good man
for gabriella and gabriella said oh my
god i hope you finished this week's
homework
i appreciate the brother coming in like
protecting his older sister that's what
little brothers should do
i think the little brother is fake no
it's no he's not yeah turquoise palm is
the name
he's not fake we'll see all right moist
i got a question for you
if given the opportunity would you
rather
live in an igloo for a week
or would you rather go to the sahara
desert
hot or cold choose wisely
yes sahara desert for a week or igloo
for a week hot our cold choose wisely
we'll see you guys tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan what
you're a bigger fan of block fight than
you are of me block flies my second
favorite thing in the world behind
polena
they've got three products they can give
you a us dollar loan
you can earn up to 8.6 interest on an
interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point percent is
pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends